[Musique]
vous
c'est une bonne chose on s'entend on est
les québécois qui sont de plus en plus à
l'extérieur on est content s'ils se
trouvent ou apprendre à gérer cet
achalandage accru le
[Musique]
quand on sait que les lichens ça pousse
à peu près points 5 mm à un millimètre
par année afin qu'il puisse imaginer
c'est hyper fragile fait qu'on puisse
imaginer une grosse botte de randonneurs
qui détruit le week-end c'est
catastrophique pour nous
[Musique]
non
je suis un éternel optimiste je pense qu
il y avait une première une première
vague des adeptes de plein air qui a
déferlé en 2020 mais si on continue à
bien éduqué je pense que l'on va aller
on peut aller dans le bon sens
ah bon
ce que j'espère aussi c'est que ça va
inciter le gouvernement les
gouvernements à créer beaucoup plus de
parcs et d'endroits où les gens puissent
aller se promener parce qu'on s'est
rendu compte à quel point c'était
important pour le monde puis à quel
point finalement il y en avait pas